attendu depuis de longs mois le projet
de loi en faveur des handicapés est
présenté aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale par rené lenoir secrétaire
d'état à l'action sociale l'amélioration
du sort du handicap et devient avec
cette loi une obligation nationale
elle donne aux intéressés ils ont 2
millions en france un certain nombre
davantage et de droits pour les plus
jeunes droit à l'éducation
placées en établissement agréé ils
seront prises en charge à 100%
ceux qui ne seront pas placés auront
droit à une allocation d'éducation
spéciale qui pourrait être doublée en
cas de prestations coûteuse pour les
adultes la loi prévoit un minimum de
ressources garanties qui libère le
handicap et de la dépendance de ses
parents 6300 francs par an
ceux qui peuvent travailler seront payés
en milieu ordinaire au niveau du smic en
milieu protégé 90 % du smic dans les
centres dead au travail 60 à 70 % du
smic pour favoriser l'insertion sociale
des handicapés des aides seront
accordées aux entreprises publiques ou
privées pour l'aménagement de postes de
travail c'est une loi de justice de
progrès social
elle ne résout pas tous les problèmes
200 amendements ont été déposés sur le
bureau de l'assemblée nationale
c'est dire que ce débat sera décisif le
vote devrait intervenir dans la nuit